there is some breaking news out of Japan
this morning a magnitude 5.7 earthquake
was felt throughout Tokyo it happened
just as typhoon a gibbous the largest
storm to hit japan in over half a
century made landfall as a category two
storm west of Tokyo
Morini Inocencio was there ramie what
did you feel good morning our building
we were in shook and rattled when that
5.7 magnitude earthquake hit the Tokyo
region just about ninety minutes ago the
city is now being pummeled by the start
of typhoon Jebus with winds sustained
winds of 100 miles per hour
Akiba s-- means speed in filipino and it
is the largest storm to hit japan in at
least six decades at least one person is
confirmed dead in chiba a man died after
a tornado flipped over his car flooding
is also reported southwest of Tokyo
rivers have swelled and boats have
overturned mudslide warnings have also
been issued the kiba's is now about to
bear down on Tokyo where the wind and
rain is only getting worse and it's
affecting a lot of people greater Tokyo
is the most heavily populated
metropolitan area on earth with over 35
million people nearly all transport
links in and out of Tokyo have come to a
halt this includes Japan's famous bullet
trains and flights into the city's 2
main airports the storm has also forced
the partial cancellation of two major
sporting events that's the formula 1 and
the Rugby World Cup this area could get
2 to 3 feet of rain overnight and that's
prompting officials to issue evacuation
warnings across the entire area while
Tokyo is really well prepared to deal
with this situation authorities are
taking no chances and they've warned
everyone to stay inside it's been at
least a generation since a typhoon like
this has ever hit Tokyo and what is one
of the world's biggest cities now looks
and feels very much like a ghost town
for CBS this morning Saturday rainy
innocencio rainy thank you